alors guillaume depardieu vous nous avez
rejoint donc je suis pas du tout
question d'un droit de réponse puisque
vous n'êtes pas gérard depardieu vous
êtes guillaume depardieu mais est ce que
votre père vous a présenté rafik khalifa
déjà non non jamais non donc vous n'avez
pas rien de spécial a déclaré finalement
non monsieur commissaire
alors guillaume depardieu après tous les
matins du monde de cornaux en 91 cible
émouvante et les apprentis de salvadori
en 93 et 95 après pola x de leos carax
199 vous êtes à la fiche de peau d'ange
le premier film de vincent pérez avec
vous morgan mort et magali voc karine
silla olivier gourmet laurent terzieff
dominique blanc valeria bruni tedeschi
voulait que face au pitch oui j'aimerais
bien puisque je suis pas très doué alors
c'est simple c'est l'histoire d'angel
qui jouait par morgan mort est une
curieuse fille qui vit dans la ferme
paternelle dans un milieu pauvre et des
vaux où on va à la messe le dimanche
matin et puis ses parents sont tellement
pauvres qu'ils doivent se résigner
envoyer leurs filles travaillé comme
bonne chez des notables de la ville et
là vous débarquez vous guillaume
depardieu vous êtes venu en fait pour
l'enterrement de votre mère mais vous
avez quitté la cérémonie pour boire un
verre parce que ça vous ça vous gonfle
voilà alors vous avez passé une nuit
ensemble pour elles c'est la première
fois qu'elle fait l'amour avec un garçon
c'est un don total elle s'abandonne
complètement alors que pour lui enfin
pau pour vous c'est plutôt une
consolation passagère non
consolation passagers
j'irai abandon nécessaire plutôt c'est à
dire qu'après tout ce que je n'ai pas
fait il fallait que je fasse quelque
chose
il fallait que je fasse quelque chose
voilà donc après cette première nuit se
séparent sur un quai de gare après
vont-ils se revoir